Ya
[Müzik]
ben Abdurrahman Koçak Biz Gaziantep'te
mobil oyunlar geliştiriyoruz
kimsenin yapmadığı bir şey yapmaya
çalıştık burada buradan Global açılmaya
çalışıyoruz Evet oyun tasarlarken de
birçok metot kullanıyoruz isterseniz
burada bir oyun tasarlayalım birlikte
bir tane kahramanımız olsun bu
kahramanımız sıradan dünyada sıradan
işlerle uğraşıyor olsun bu arada bir
krizle karşılaştı bir sorunla
karşılaştım bu sorunu çözmek için de
yola koyulur Tabi bu yola koyulduğunda
bir Bilge dediğimiz olsun bu Bilge Dede
olana bazı öğütler versin Bu aldığı
öğütlerle Bilge den aldığı öğütlerle
bu sıradan dünyadan özel bu giriş yapsın
Bu dünyada bazı bilmeceleri çözsün bazı
küçük Canavarları öldürsün ama ulaşmak
istediği ve korkulu rüyası büyük
canavara ulaşsın bu canavar
var kendisini al test bir yumrukla ve
bir kriz yaşansın bu krizde Bilge den
aldığı öğütlerle bir çözüme ulaştım
bizim kahramanımız kalksın yeniden
birisin ve gitsin bu canavarı 6 test
Tabi bu canavar alt ettikten sonra bir
ödüle kavuşsun o aldığı ödülle
eski hayatına yani sıradan hayata
dönüşmüş bir şekilde tecrübe lenmiş bir
şekilde tekrar döviz ve yine buradaki
çözümle bu aldığı edindiği tecrübeyle
oradaki sorunu çözsün sıradan hayat bu
ire devam et
güzel bir oyun oldu mu böyle bir oyun
olsa oynardınız belki değil mi Aslında
birçok
filmde birçok masalda birçok hikaye de
bu örüntüyü görüyorsunuz yani böyle bir
şablon var bu şablonu Joseph Campbell
üretmiş zamanında
gördüğünüz gibi bir kahraman var sıradan
bir durumlar sonra bir sorun oluşuyor ve
özel bir dünyaya atılıp özel görevler
yapıp oradan aldığımız ödüller de bir
şeyler yapıyoruz
kendi ayaklarımızda bunu kurtuluyoruz
değil mi bu hikâyelerle kendi
ayaklarımızda da karşı karşıya kalıyoruz
Tamam belki canavar öldürmüyor uzama
canavar kadar o Canavarlar kadar
korkutucu sorunlarla yüzleşmek
istemediğimiz sorunlarla yüzleşip bazı
bu isimleri yaşayıp ve tekrar sıradan
hayatımıza bir level atlamış bir şekilde
tekrar göndür ümüz çok zaman olmuştur
bunu Aslında Çocukken daha sık yapardık
sorunlarla karşılaştığımızda pes
etmezdik o sorunu aşmanın Bir yolu
bulurduk bir şekilde
çocuklarınız vardır belki çocuklarınızın
Ya bunu nasıl yapmış Buradan nasıl
Kurtulmuş dediğinizi Belki siz de şahit
olmuşsunuzdur oradaki çocuğu da
görüyorsunuz
bir şekilde o maceranın içerisine
girmekten korkmayıp
oradan yeni şeyler öğrenecek dönüşerek
biraz daha tecrübe kazanarak
geçiyor ama
bizim dönüşme miz için şu an
biraz sert bir şey mı gerekiyor
Ne
dediler ki
bu arkadaşımız yazmış üç yıl diş
tedavisi gördüm Şubat ayında iken Doktor
çok olağanüstü bir durum olmazsa
Nisan'da teller çıkacak demişti çok
olağanüstü bir durum oldu Evet cawwot
denen bir vakayla karşılaştık hiç
beklemiyorduk Hazırlıklı değildik birçok
şeyi yapış şeklimizi değişti ya Böyle
olur mu dediğimiz her şey oldu ya yüz
yüze eğitim olması lazım uzaktan da
eğitim oldu
o iş ofis olması lazım ofiste
çalışılması lazım uzaktan çalışılabilir
diyani adapte olduk Aslında bir çok
alışkanlığımızı
değiştirmek durumunda kaldık bir krizi
neticesinde bir sorunun neticesinde
Tabi biz buna hala
direniyoruz bunu geçici bir şey olarak
görüyoruz Yani bir gün kalkacağız pandem
evet hadi artık eski Hayatımıza devam
edelim diyeceğiz
Aslında yeni normal denen bir şey var
Buna adapte olmaya başlayacağız
ilerleyen dönemde Şimdi ben iki şeyden
bahsettim bir değişmekten bahsettim Bir
de dövüşmekten bahsettim bu kavramları
da bir netleştirmek istiyorum demiş
değişim aslında dış etkilere
gösterdiğimiz bir tek
yani istenen bir sonucu elde etmek için
bizim
hareketlerimizi eylemlerimizi modifiye
etme Şeklimiz dönüşüm ise biraz daha
uzun vadeli Aslında temel inançları da
değiştirerek Belki bizim uzun vadeli
davranışlarımızı da değiştirerek ve bu
değişim zincirini güzel planlayarak
değiştirmek bütün hayatımızı inancımızı
organizasyonu muzu değiştirmek olarak
tanımlayabiliriz ya Ya aslında
biz yeni modeller keşfetmemiz gerekiyor
Bu tarz böyle Krizlere özellikle ele
daha az maruz kalabilmek için 7
modelleri planlamak
değiştirecek şeyleri adım adım planlamak
gerekiyor yeni normalden bahsettik yeni
normal aslında
bir örnek Vereceğim bir arkadaşım şey de
çalışıyor
Bir emeklilik şirketinde e uzaktan
çalıştıkları dönemde iki kat daha
verimli çalıştıklarını keşfettiler bu
büyük bir emeklilik şirketi Bu arada
İstanbul'da çok merkezi bir yerde çok
lüks de bir ofisleri var binaları var ve
ciddi kiralar veriyorlardı Sizce bu
firma artık dönüp o yerde çalışmaya
devam edecek mi yoksa uzaktan bu
sistemine adapte olup bütün kurgularının
bunun üzerine mi yapacak şimdi diyoruz
yani Birden her şey bitecek pandomim
edecek Biz eski hayatlarımıza döneceğiz
eski Hayat diye bir durum yok
yeni normal var Yeni Hayat var işte bu
dönüşümden sonra Geldiğimiz Yer olacak
aslında birçok şeyden bahsediyor Mustafa
hocam da zaten biraz önce çok detaylı
anlattı Yapay Zeka büyük veri endüstri40
nesnelerin interneti
gik'e Evet bir dijital dönüşüm
başlamıştı biz buna direnenler
bu grubunda yaydık belki ama bir mesaj
bir problem bizim Bunun farkına varmamız
ı sağlık kalktık belki birçok şeyi
değiştirerek bu dönüşümün içerisine
girdik
Tesla'nın o turu otonom arabalarını
görüyorsunuz öğrendiği şeylerle Bizden
çok iyi araba kullanıyor Bizden çok
dikkatli Birçok Kez bu oynuyor
Bu makine öğrenmeden bahsediliyordu
değil mi yapay zekanın alt kümelerinden
bir tanesi Aslında makine öğrenme Ne
yapıyor bizim öğrenme modelimizi
matematiksel bir bir şeye dönüştürüyor
modele dönüştürüyor bunu kurguluyor
ve bunu bilgisayara anlatıyor şu şekilde
öğreneceksin bu şekilde öğreneceksin
şöyle bir sonuç varsa şu veride
işlediğinde şunu görüyorsan şuradan
aldığın resimde bunu görüyorsan şu
kararı vereceksin diye makinelere
öğretiyor Aslında yapay zekanın yese
bile değil şu an Yapay Zeka bundan çok
daha fazlasını yapacak bizim yerimize de
düşünecek yani yeni soyut düşünceleri
kurulacak bu soyut düşüncelere yeni
çözümler bulacak ve bunu da yüz binlerce
kat belki bizden daha hızlı yapacak bu
dönüşüm başlamıştı bir farkında değildik
bizim farkında olmamız için bir şeyler
gerekiyordu bu ve öğrendik on yıl
öncesindeki meslekleri düşünün şimdi kim
eşit meslekleri düşünün
birçok meslek gitti yeni meslekler geldi
abi ve hala da bu dönüşüm devam ediyor
yeni yeni meslekler oluşuyor Eee
otonom bir şekilde yapılan meslekler
yerini ör robotlara bırakıyorsa hocanın
verdiği örnekte ye artık yemeği bile
bile değil mi mi robotlar yapabilecek
konuma geldi şu resmi görüyorsunuz Duru
fotoğrafta Daha doğrusu resimde miyim bu
fotoğrafta bir meslek var
Ve biliyor musunuz
uyandırma servis Belki 50 yıl önce
altmış yıl önce Neyse insanlar alarmı
diye bir kavram olmadığı için çalar saat
diye bir kavram olmadığı için birilerine
para verirlermiş ve sabah erken
saatlerde birileri gelip camlarına
tıklatarak onları uyandırmış çok komik
geliyor değil mi böyle birşey yapılıyor
Çok saçma meslekti ama belki Bundan on
sene sonra
şu anki halimize bile gülecek durumda
olacağız
iyice eski ya nelerle uğraşıyor muyuz
şunları İş olarak yapıyormuşuz Düşünsene
bunu makineler yapıyor Biz daha önemli
işlerle uğraşma mız lazım mı
Biz işte burada sınıfta kalıyor gibiyiz
biraz ama Bitcoin diye bir şey çıktı
blokzincir
anlatıldı anlatıldı Bitcoin hala bir
para birimi olarak görüyoruz Aslında bu
ciddi bir devrim diyen tüm dünyadaki
bilgisayarları kullanarak aynı anda bazı
işlemleri yapma bu verileri o
bilgisayarlara dağınık bir şekilde
dağıtıp bir şekilde işlem eydi burada
amaç hala Doğu yapılıyor bir sürü işte
sorhocam da örnek verdi üç boyutlu
yazıcıdan çıkan organlar çıktığı
yüzden sadece fotoğraftan genetik
hastalık teşhisi yapılabiliyor şu an
nanobotlar kanımıza geliyor kanımızdan
ilgili yerlere giderek nerede ha ha
arıza olduğunu çok rahat anlayabiliyor
bu arızaları gidermek için bir şeyler
yapabiliyor
sanal sunucular çıktı ya bu
gerçek değil bu sunucu A haber sunucusu
bildiğiniz Haber sunucuları gibi Bu
elleri günlük televizyon ekranında bu
sınav sonucu da dinleyebiliyorsunuz
otonom arabalar çıktı bahsettik işte
artık şeyi tam anlamıyla sanal
gerçekliği tam anlamıyla yaşamak için
sanal gerçeklik giysileri bile çıktı
ama bunlar çıkarken Teknoloji bu
dönüşümün içerisine girmiş yeni şeyler
üretirken Biz yavaş ladık Nasılsa bizim
yerimize buna bilgileri yapıyor dedik
Slash tık bayağı ulaştık
Biz aslında bu savaşta biraz mağlub
durumdayız yani teknolojinin dönüşümüne
Biz ayak uyduramıyorum tuz 2 bin bir
otobüse Bey son sey filmi var Belki
izlemişsinizdir orada da anlatılan
anatema şuydu insana bir yetenek
veriliyor üretme yeteneği insan Red MEye
ba o ürettikçe yeni şeyler öğretiyor
öğreniyor yeni şeyler üretiyor sonra bir
devirden sonra
konuşmaları bile basit leşiyor
çok sıradan anlaşıyor
bu
dijital dönüşüm bu kadar ilerlemiş Ken
Aslında 1968 yapımı bir film Bu arada
biz orada sınıfta kaldığımızı çok rahat
görebiliyoruz zaten
hocam da dediğim gibi bahsetti Bir
tehlike ile karşı karşıyayız
Teknoloji bu kadar gelişmiş Ken biz bu
dönüşüme küçük değişikliklerle ayak
uydurmaya başladık
Ya aslında gittikçe dediğim gibi mağlup
olduk şu an bu krizin için içindeyiz
başta bir hikaye anlatmıştım hikaye
örgüsü anlatmıştım bir şablon
anlatmıştım Evet şu an tam o şablondaki
alt bölgedeyiz kriz içerisindeyiz sizde
Burada şimdi bizim dönüşüme ayak
uydurmak için kendimizi dönüştürmek için
kalkıp yeniden Sen bu Bilge den
aldığımız öğütlerle yeniden bir şeyler
yapmamız ve bu krizi alt etmemiz
gerekiyor
mı yoksa
insanlık tarihini çok güzel şeyler
beklemiyor diyebiliriz Tabi bunu nasıl
yapacağız
değişmek dönüşmek Evet bunlardan
bahsettik ama değişmeyen bile tam olarak
yapamıyor Ken nasıl dövüşeceğiz
kişilik bir çay istiyorlar
ecnebilere Değişimi de planlarken bu
küçük değişiklikleri de planlarken küçük
küçük değişikliklerle Yani aslında yeni
alışkanlıklar edilecek şekilde
planlamamız gerektiğini söylüyorlar Biz
şu anki
alışkanlıklarımıza baktığımız zaman bu
değişiklikleri bile yapamayacak
durumdayken nasıl dönüşüme Ece cesaret
edeceğiz demeyin Bunu yapabilecek
gerçekten küçük alışkanlıklarımızı
değiştirdiğimiz ama bunu yapabilecek
güçlü olduğumuzu bilelim
en
başta da söylediğim gibi
değişmeyelim dönüş elimden sadece
değişik değişmeyelim dönüşme yolunda
değişikliğe değişme odaklanalım dönüşümü
odaklanır Pardon Teşekkür ediyorum beni
izlediğiniz için sağolun
[Müzik]